On est sur le spot numéro deux
de la journée.
On va voir ce qu’il y a ici, c’est un petit ruisseau qui ne paie pas de mine
Mais je vous assure qu'on va trouver
des choses et on en a déjà trouvé.
On est encore en compagnie
de Wim, de Danny et de Quentin
On va aller dans l'eau tout de suite.
Je suis prêt
Allé c’est parti
Je suis presque tombé
Voyons voir ce qu’il y a
Une bouteille.
Oh oui, elle est pleine.
Tu peux la boire !
Ca sent quoi ?
Malibu ?
Non, c'est du sirop d'orgeat ou du Ricard
Vous en voulez ?
Là j’ai quelque chose
Nul
Il a une arme
Une arme de 1850
Incroyable mec !
Bravo
Un fusil à percution
Un fusil à poudre noir
Très cool
Félicitation
Voilà, on voulait une arme, aujourd’hui on l’a faite
Super
C’est cool
Une très belle trouvaille
de notre ami Wim.
N'hésitez pas, à aller jeter un coup
d'œil à sa chaîne qui sera affichée ici
Une clef, une vieille clef
Elle est vide
Du calibre 12
On est motivé pour faire d’autres armes.
Là une casserole
C'est pas mal
L’odeur elle est encore pire ici
Une X-Box, non ?
Peut être un coffre fort
C’est un radiateur
Double confort.
Un radiateur.
On est de l'autre côté du pont.
On espère trouver d'autres armes
comme celle là, d’époque
Il va falloir bien creuser dans la vase.
C'est parti !
Il y a des morceaux de métal
Un morceau de pot d'échappement
Ca vient
Une pelle
On fait la pêche dans la jungle
On essaie de bien enfoncer dans la vase
Pour sortir les vieilles choses comme le fusil de Wim
Elle pue un peu cette eau
Ca sent les égouts.
Regardez, Danny vient de trouver un viseur laser d’airsoft
C’est drôle, bonne trouvaille
Ouais, super trouvaille.
Tu veux un tube ?
Bravo Quentin, beau tuyau
C’est un ancien, cassette
Un vieux poste à cassette ouais
Il est beau
Il est en bon état
Il faut le mettre dans le riz
Pathé-Marconi ?
Pathé-Marconi, la voix de son maître.
C’est vraiment le bordel, on va nettoyer les bouteilles et tout
Bonjour.
La pêche est bonne ?
C’est la grande pêche
On pose tout là, on récupère après
Pour pêcher
Il y a des choses intéressantes
Elle est sympa
Encore une fourchette, j’avais même pas vu
Elles sont propres à chaque fois
J’ai d'autres choses là.
Un autre couteau
Deux couteaux
Vous avez toute une collection.
Un autre
Il est beau celui-là
Du pâté
C'est une lampe
Une serrure
Encore un couteau
Il est beau
Pour manger les moules
Il est joli celui là.
Le couteau est sympa.
Il est cassé
Le couteau, il est cassé.
C’est un couteau sympathique
Dommage.
Oh purée !
Encore un moulinet de pêche
J’ai trouvé une lampe
C'est joli ça.
J’y ai cru,
Encore un
Qui c'est qui s'énerve comme ça à la pêche ?
Pour la pêche à l’aimant
Incroyable
Le premier aimant
Merci à tous
d'avoir regarder cette vidéo de pêche à l’aimant
On se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Peut être en compagnie de Wim et Danny
qui restent encore quelques jours avec nous.
Maintenant,
on va aller se rincer dans la mer.
Oui, on en a bien besoin.
Et encore une fois, n'hésitez pas,
vous avez la chaîne de Wim
en description de la vidéo.
N’oubliez pas le pouce vers le haut
On va se baigner dans la mer Rasta ?
Tu as un copain en plus ?
Il m’embête
Il est en forme